wer sich heute gerade 2000 leute da gibt
es fliegende autos dieser serie mit 40
millionen likes man kennt das ja bereits
es immer zum jahresende so statistiken
rauskommen die beispielsweise von
spotify hey das ging 2018 ab das futter
meisten gehört das waren die meist
gespielten künstler du hast gibt
selbstverständlich auch jedes jahr von
instagram wo die einfach sagen hey das
waren die meisten bilder videos dieses
jahr wenn man sich die top 10 meist
geleiteten instagram beiträge des jahres
2018 anschaut sieht man direkt das
sieben davon allein von cristiano
ronaldo und kalidünger sind beschweren
kann ich mich da normalerweise eher
weniger fans von laser luca leider aber
ich würde sagen wir schauen uns mal
aufsteigen
die meisten bilder an und zwar auf platz
10 cristiano ronaldo mit seiner frau in
dubai habe ich auch den wunsch als
nächstes haben wir dann hier ein foto
von kylie jenner mit ihrem baby das hat
einfach 11,9 millionen likes so viel
haben meine ganzen
haben wir die ganzen bilder zusammen so
viel check-in slater also im jahr 2018
habe ich 72 bilder auf instagram
hochgeladen und die hatten alle zusammen
13,1 millionen likes danke dafür hat sie
mir übrigens noch nicht auf instagram
folglich heißt laser luca allerdings
machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten platz und zwei es auch kylie
jenner dessen schönes foto ist es sie
mit ihrem kind die nächsten platz belegt
dann dieses bild von cristiano ronaldo
wohl verkündet hat dass er zu juventus
turin wechselt das nächstes auf
cristiano ronaldo das ist eine ganze
familie beim ansehen
das ist silvester genauso kam an
weihnachten natürlich das nächste foto
stan ariana grandy mit mac miller
das hat sie einige tage nach seinem tod
hochgeladen davor ist natürlich wieder
kylie jenner mit einem foto vaas 13
millionen likes hat das nächste foto ist
dann von es ist traurig eigentlich dass
in den top ten
zwei bilder sind von personen die trotz
sind dann haben wir auf platz 2 justin
bieber und haye die baldwin also diesen
langen text den er geschrieben hat so
von wegen dass er sie über alles liebt
die cetera pp und platz eins ist dieses
bild von kylie jenner stormy webster 18
5 millionen likes wieder ein foto von
ihrem kind und da hat man sich gedacht
hey 18 eineinhalb millionen likes kann
es überhaupt noch krasser werden auf
instagram und ich meine dieses bild
wurde am 6 februar 2018 hochgeladen also
es ist noch nicht einmal ein jahr
draußen und ihr seht schon im titel
eingeblendet es geht heute um dieses ei
eventuelle fragen sich jetzt viele von
euch hey luca warum geht es denn heute
um das hat doch nichts mit den ganzen
bildern zu tun oder mit diesen
statistiken was sind die meisten
beiträge auf instagram oder die meist
gehörten songs auf spotify dieses eine
liebe lucio meine sehr verehrten
zuschauer
auf instagram innerhalb von elf tagen
40 millionen likes gesammelt wenn ich
das ganze mal aktualisiere sehen wir es
hat immer noch 40 millionen likes
[Musik]
mir fehlen das wirklich die worte ich
bin auf diese aufmerksam geworden vor
einigen tagen und ich habe es auch in
meine story gepackt und ab da einfach
nur 2009/10 punkt punkt punkt
zugeschrieben das bild von diesem wurde
also vor elf tagen hochgeladen
also heute ist der 15 erst und es hat in
diesen elf tagen 40,8 millionen likes
gesammelt die aktualisierte jetzt noch
mal essen gerade 819 und jetzt sind es
einfach 828 wow 9000 likes in paar
sekunden und ich meine man darf wirklich
auch nicht außer acht lassen dass dieses
foto auch einfach zwei millionen
kommentare hat sein gott verdammtes bild
von einem run auf das einfach mal drauf
klickt sieht man schon dass hier
verschiedene einflussreiche magazine wie
beispielsweise mashable buzzfeed oder
auch nachrichten seiner vision markiert
wurden unter anderem auch judith und das
hier ist das profil von
blauen hatten ein kopf verdammte scheiße
hat einen blauen haken auf instagram der
account hat 5,8 millionen abonnenten sie
haben einen beitrag dass es wie gesagt
dieses ei wird diese zahlen sind so
surreal jeder zweite deutsche hat dieses
bild geliked account folgt 925 leuten
davon sind die meisten wirklich personen
mit einem blauen haken also
wahrscheinlich war das auch einfach nur
noch mehr puts von wegen haye zeigt
unser bestätigt dass einfach alles
andere die haben einfach sogar
merchandise also dass das ist wirklich
haben
ich bestelle mir so ein t shirt nur
wenige minuten später oder konfirmation
[Musik]
ich bin ein wahrer fan auf jeden fall
ist das hier dieser account world
unterstrich record unterstrich also der
account der dieses bild von ich finds
immer noch ich kann es nicht oft genug
sagen 40 millionen likes dass ich mache
bei einem guten foto an die 200 300.000
likes 40 millionen für ein gott
verdammtes man muss allerdings dazu
sagen das ist schon sehr schönes foto
von dem eis das ein hat auch eine story
[Musik]
ja cool wie haben sie denn die story
gepackt dass sie im blauen haken
bekommen haben sagt sie hier
mtv schaut sogar was dazu gepostet haile
when she's the world record account
anscheinend hat sich kai die auch dazu
geäußert also das hier ist kein ließ
instagram account
die schon nicht
so hässlich allgemeine es ist halt so
krass was die vielleicht macht hier zehn
millionen einfach hier auch 83 millionen
was hatte hier noch mit ihrem kind auf
7,2 millionen 6,7 millionen und hier 30
millionen aufrufe wir schauen dass kylie
jenner in diesem video über das gesagt
hat
das dach schon
halt es hat jetzt wahrscheinlich gegen
demmin page zusammengeschnitten so von
wegen oder teil die mal mit dem ei
interagiert das ist aber gut dass sie
war auf jeden fall kann dies reaktion
auf das world record einmal schauen was
sie noch in ihrer story drin hat gehen
wir zurück geht
trauriges mai diesfalls regnen und ihre
ganzen luxury cars werden also klar ich
habe letzte woche gelesen sie ist die
erste selfmade milliardärinnen unter 22
regen wieso also komplett pops an dich
hier mit deinem keine kosmetik krams und
so weiter allein dass das mal 840.000
das heißt nur jeder mensch träumt von
solchen zahlen aber sie lebt natürlich
schon krass in ihrem luxus film aber gut
wenn man milliardärin ist dass ich meine
guckt euch an wie das kind angezogen ist
ich würde nie viel geld für
kinderklamotten ausgeben weil die doch
in einem jahr das gar nicht mehr tragen
können aber ich glaube wirklich wenn man
so viel geld verdient dann weiß man
nicht mehr wohin mit dem ganzen kram
hier auch vom privatjet komplett
wahnsinn aber es soll ja heute gar nicht
um kylie jenner gehen sondern um das ja
ich wunderschön wikipedia hatten und
mittlerweile nämlich schon seit den
einigen tagen in denen jetzt nun das i-
das meiste bild ist und kylie jenner vom
thron gestoßen hat haben die schon ihren
artikeln zu den list of most leicht
instagram post updated bis liscon
tamestit ob boni kostenlosem ausgleichs
und eine foto und video sharing social
platform instagram dem ausgleich post
und instagram ist potter-fan equity
point for millionen likes derek ist auch
so eine maus leicht internetpost of all
time was ist denn mit des partito also
das passierte hat 5,8 milliarden das hat
31 millionen likes nur zu geben gibt es
ja auch noch ziehen hat 22 millionen
likes achtung scheiße das heißt das eis
nicht nur das meiste legte foot of
instagram sondern das meist geklickte
ding überhaupt gründlich heute gerade
2000 leute da gibt's siegte hause und
sagen dieser serie mit 40 millionen
likes anderer stelle durch das heutige
wir jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat das gerne mal einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video da und wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal seit der
klicks auf abonnierten und dann auf die
glocke weil dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und ihr könnt coole
kommentare wie erster oder so schreiben
und ganz viele lecks sammeln sowie das
ei auf instagram teilte das foto vom
world record at noch nicht gelegt haben
sollte dass der beitrag auf jeden fall
nochmal unten in der beschreibung
verlinkt dort und ist auch mein
instagram verlinkt ist ein laser luca da
könnt ihr auch gerne folgen denkst
ich habe mir einfach gedacht hey dieses
verdammte mittlerweile schon 40
millionen leipzig muss dazu ein video
machen
dieses braucht noch mehr aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]